another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do with the foundation no placing  pranks in new staff's desks and  liquefying them in record time starting  a new job can be a stressful experience  figuring out the office culture choosing  a coffee cup in the break room and  deciding which funko pops look best on  your desk it's a lot to think about the  last thing a new employee needs is to  sit down at their brand new desk open a  drawer to grab a pen and have their  flesh melted from their skull by a  bright blast of mysterious green light  it's not funny we're not impressed  anymore and staff turnover at the  foundation is already high enough as it  is  no more pranks it's not a rite of  passage if they don't survive at dr  bright